rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message take accountability
over to you Simon signing in the 18th
century there was something that spread
across Europe and eventually made its
way to America where pole fever also
known as the Black Death of childbed
basically what was happening is women
were giving birth and they would die
within 48 hours after giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century in some hospitals it was as
high as 70 percent of women who gave
birth who would die as a result of
giving birth but this was the
Renaissance this was the time of
empirical data and science and we had
thrown away things like tradition and
mysticism these were men of science
these were doctors and these doctors and
men of science wanted to study and try
and find the reason for this black death
of childbed and so they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses of the of the women who had died
and in the morning they would conduct
autopsies and then in the afternoon they
would go and deliver babies and finish
their rounds and it wasn't until
somewhere in the mid 1800s that dr.
Oliver Wendell Holmes father of Supreme
Court justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
realized that all of these doctors who
conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies in the afternoon and he
pointed it out and said guys you're the
problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy for 30 years until finally
somebody realized that if they simply
washed their hands it would go away
and that's exactly what happened when
they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands the
black death of childbed disappeared my
point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem we've seen this
happen all too recently with our new men
of science and empirical studies and
these men of Finance who are smarter
than the rest of us until the thing
collapsed and they blamed everything
else except themselves and my point is
is take accountability for your actions
you can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right as long
as you also take responsibility for the
things you do wrong it must be a
balanced equation you don't get it one
way and not the other you get to take
credit when you also take accountability
that's lesson 2 you will make
significant progress towards your goals
when you realize that it's not just
sometimes you're the problem all the
time you're the problem take extreme
accountability and ownership for where
you are in your life right now it's
nobody else's fault but your own when I
was setting up this morning I was
talking to Jason my cameraman and he was
talking about how he first joined me
when he was when we were under a hundred
thousand subscribers now we're over a
million and that's amazing and we've
been able to touch so many lives and I
deserve to be at a million with the team
that I have with you guys supporting
with the quality of videos that we're
putting out we deserve to have a million
subscribers but we don't deserve to have
ten million subscribers that's the next
goal that's where I'm going and that's
entirely my fault
I'm the reason why we're not at ten
million subscribers it's not the
YouTube's algorithms fault it's not a
lack of resources it's me it's me and
understand that I need to get better on
film I need to get my team pulling up
their straps and getting better
everything that is wrong with my
business with my channel is because of
me and when you take that kind of
accountability first off it's it sucks
because it's nice to have somebody to
blame right it's it'd be great to be
able to blame
the YouTube algorithm it'd be great to
be able to blame my parents or education
system or the president or the
government that's the reason why I'm not
more successful right that's the reason
why I'm not able to achieve my big goals
it's somebody else's fault as long as we
can place that blame on somebody else
then we feel great about ourselves
because it's not our fault and we can
just sit back and complain it's your
fault that I'm not achieving my goals so
as soon as you realize that it's
entirely your fault
it sucks what it's also liberating
because it's within your control because
you can't change your upbringing you
can't change who your parents are you
can't change your education you had you
can't change a lot of things in your
environment you can't change the YouTube
algorithm or whatever else you think is
causing a problem but you can't change
yourself you can't change what you do
every day and when you stop blaming
other people and circumstances and start
taking personal accountability for where
you are in life and you take the
responsibility to make it better for
yourself and the people around you
that's when things start to change
you may say well that's not fair it's
not fair that my employee walked out on
me or this huge collapse happen in the
market it's not fair
but if you can say that's my fault it's
my fault for not recognizing that was
going to happen it's my fault for not
working hard with my fault for
complaining all the way through it
instead of finding a solution everything
is your fault when you start from that
position and you take that
accountability and ownership that's when
things really start to take off for your
business and your goals so the question
today is I'm curious what is one thing
you've been blaming somebody else for
that now you are gonna take personal
responsibility for leave it in comments
below I'm really curious to find that I
also want to give a quick shout-out to
Tuan nuyen from dude Buddha he picked up
ten copies of my first book you're one
word and now fifty-five copies of my
next book the top ten moves to success
Tuan thank you so much for the love and
support man he's buying his gifts for
his clients and I really appreciate it
hope they have a fantastic holiday
season so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events
so I work spray so give me
it's taken no less than 100%
responsibility for your life you know
one of the greatest myths that's
pervasive in our culture today is that
you're entitled to a great life and then
somehow somewhere someone is responsible
for filling our lives with continual
happiness and exciting career options a
nurturing family and blissful personal
relationships simply because we exist
but the real truth is that there's only
one person responsible for the quality
of your life and that person is you you
see everything about you is a result of
your doing or not doing your income your
debt your relationships your health your
fitness level your attitudes and
behaviors everything that person you see
when you look in the mirror is the chief
architect in your life you know I think
everybody knows this in their heart of
hearts but the mind can play games
tricking us into thinking that there are
external factors that are the source of
our failures our disappointments and our
unhappiness but the truth of the matter
is that external factors don't determine
how you live you and only you are in
complete control of the quality of your
life experience successful people take
full responsibility for the thoughts
they think the images they visualize and
the actions they take they don't waste
their time and energy on blaming and
complaining they evaluate their
experiences and decide if they need to
change them or not they face the
uncomfortable and they take risks in
order to create the life that they want
to live there is no such thing as
complete control
nothing no one has complete control in
any situation people that leading
organizations in some ways have less
because not only do they have to control
what they do they have to help persuade
everyone else what they do but you know
if you are able to take responsibility
I'm not late because there was traffic
I'm late because I didn't leave early
enough to account for the fact that
there was traffic the project didn't get
finished not because my friend my
partner didn't do it
my colleague didn't do his part the
thought the project didn't get finished
because I didn't set up a team where my
colleague
to do his part when you take
responsibility and you take full
responsibility that is the most
empowering thing and you can do it at
any stage you have to do it if you're
raising money as an entrepreneur you
have to do it if you are if you're
trying to persuade people to work with
you you have to do it at all stages in
the home or out of the home we all work
so if we all have 24 hours in a day we
all live on planet Earth and we all work
what are you doing with your time
because people like a Bill Gates or the
late Steve Jobs they had lived on planet
earth they had 24 hours in a day and
they worked why is it that they made so
much more money than the rest of us
because there is a variable in the
equation of success and that variable is
you it's you not your government that
you're working under not the boss not
the business it's not the manufacturing
not the product on the service you and
what you do with what you have you see
when I first got started in business you
know as a homeless broke fat cocktail
waitress well the business that kind of
presented itself to me if you will was
actually sitting in my back seat it was
not something that I wanted to do but as
a cocktail waitress I knew that I'd be
homeless for another three months and I
knew it I would never pay off my $35,000
in debt making the amount that I was
making as a cocktail waitress so I came
to that conclusion
hopefully you're coming to the same
conclusion this is not gonna work I have
to find a way to generate more income
well that business that was in the back
seat of my car really wasn't that
business it was a product it was a
product that I wasn't interested in it
was a product that didn't work for me it
was a product that I had no credibility
in it was in the weight loss industry I
was fat who was gonna listen to me I'm
fat who's gonna listen to me
I didn't even like this product that's
how come I was sitting in the back of my
car instead of actually me using it well
I didn't believe in it I didn't like it
it wasn't my lifelong dream and passion
it wasn't the right business and my
opinion at that time but
I had to step up and become the right
person in order to get out of debt to
make more money and to make a change in
my life rather than waiting around for
someone to sail in and save the day
yeah I had to make some serious changes
you know and that's unfortunate because
people are struggling right now they're
waiting for someone to take the problems
away they're waiting for someone to
change the circumstances they're waiting
to be found
they're waiting for somebody to make all
the difference for them there is no
somebody actually I have to correct
myself
you are the somebody it's you if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details